leute ich bin schon am 27 06 also schon
in vier wochen auf dem xx über day in
bottrop im movie park tickets alles in
der video beschreibung wirklich mega
freuen wenn ich wieder von euch sehen
jetzt viel spaß mit dem video
er wollte was klappt netz bekommen
bayern ein video und zwar habe ich ja
letztens irgendwann mal zehn arten von
snap chat nutzern also darf holz und
video gemacht fällt zehn arten so ihr
wisst schon und das auch ganz gut bei
euch angekommen dadurch begabten von was
kannst du denn jetzt mal so 10 art
machen und da habe ich mir gedacht ganz
typisch war so zehn arten von whatsapp
nutzer whatsapp hat jeder benutzt jeder
zumindest fast jeder und ich würde sagen
das gibt es heute wenn es übrigens noch
um da und jetzt viel spaß gefangen
natürlich an mit ihm ein ja und zwar ist
dass dieser typ der einfach egal was du
schreibst er antwortet immer mit
sprachnotizen selbst wenn du die nicht
mehr abfangen kann schreibt ich kann ja
nicht abhören komplotts mit sprachen
tipps hatte ich mir hey was ist denn los
mit dir so da guck mal was mir
geschrieben von benny hey wie gehts mir
geht's gut und dir was ich gerade mache
ja alles gibt schild auf meinem sofa und
machen sprachen für dich ach so du
kannst es gerade gar nicht anhören ja
alles klar
dann hört jetzt einfach später so ok
warum hast du dir jetzt gerade so aus
verstehe ich nicht der zweite typ
das ist der der einfach hinter jede
nachricht ihr schreibt sollen 10 zeigen
langes haar dranhängt kennt ihr noch
oder das ist doch auch wenn es gar nicht
passt kommt er trotzdem hinten dran
ja das war echt lustig und wie geht's
dir so ja danke danach war jetzt auch
gut
warum hängen nicht ganz
dahinter passt doch eigentlich gar nicht
ja ach nee fällt euch das nicht auf
vordermann machen wir weiter mit typ 3
und zwar ist dass dieser typ der
eigentlich nur alle 3 tage online ist
aber wenn man ihm eine nachricht
schreibt antwortete er direkt an zuerst
dann direkt online kinder etwas anteil
zuletzt online vor drei tagen lohnt sich
das jetzt war die ich schreibe einfach
etwas hatten wir in mathe
das ging ja schnell hat die keine
freunde
typ 4 das hat mir richtig auf das ist
dieser typ der stellt bei sprachnotizen
immer so viele fragen in einer sprache
offiziell meisten auch noch so fünf
minuten lang ist und man kann halt nur
die hälfte davon behalten und dann
darauf eingehen auch so her wenn das so
ist auf jeden fall cool und was machst
du dazu also bei mir ist nicht so viel
los ist illegal so ein bisschen wetter
ist ja auch nicht so bombe kannst du ja
mal erzählen wieder ein tag war und ach
ja wenn du wenn du weißt du morgens
petra wird kannst du es auch direkt mit
dem check in wird mich auch freuen
gestern hat ist doch dieses fußballspiel
wie habt ihr eigentlich habt ihr
gewonnen habt ihr verloren erzählt auf
master tor geschossen und der eu rat
auch noch geburtstag alles gute von mir
und frag ich mal nur das nächste mal
wieder so alles so etwas machen wollen
wir das ja auf jeden fall cool ja der
doch darauf seine freundin jetzt oder so
lange sind sie schon zusammen weißt du
was wir in mathe aufgaben noch nie so
ganz am rande weil matte muss ich
vielleicht auch noch mal deutsch auch
noch also mathe deutsch und englisch
wenn du da die hoffnung ist es schon
was hast du denn fürn gedächtnis das war
jetzt vielleicht acht fragen oder so die
kann man doch mal beantworten und der
nächsten typ den gibt's eigentlich
überall
das ist so der da denkt man sich so ist
er sein leben lang schlecht drauf
schreibt einfach alles meins man denkt
halt ist er sauer auf mich fragt er mich
nicht sehr einfach ein bisschen
emotionslos zu halten
ja mir geht es ausgezeichnet punkt ja
das wetter ist echt schön heute da hast
du recht punkt ob irgendwas habe
hat er denn wieso sollte ich irgendwas
haben fragezeichen
und weil ich keine smileys schreibe hält
das hat doch überhaupt gar nichts damit
zu tun wie es mir geht und weiß auch
schon beim typ nummer keine ahnung wie
viel auf jeden fall ist das der der halt
für fünf wörter zum beispiel zehn jahre
woche oder so zum beispiel bei meiner
mutter ist das so da denkt man so
schreibt schreibt schreibt man macht
sich schon so voll die gerinnung schwein
ist was kommt jetzt hab ich irgendwas
falsch gemacht oder einkommen fünf
wörter was schreib dir denn weder
solange ich bin doch schon längst
zuhause glücklich habe ich irgendwas
falsch gemacht was vergessen
ich bin ganz schön nervös was kommt denn
jetzt wie es mir geht
alter dein ernst der nächste typ der ich
mich auch so richtig auf und zwar ist
das der typ du christ sprach jetzt dies
zwei minuten lang oder so hört sie ab
und nur fünf oder zehn sekunden davon
ist vernünftiger inhalt und was ich
damit meine ist das ja also pass auf das
war so ich bin halt ausgegangen um die
ecke und drei kammern direkt das auto
hat mich ohne scheiß fast eingefahren ja
warte was wirklich noch sein
fünf minuten später
weitere fünf minuten später sind weiß
auch schon beim letzten typ und zwar die
stalker von euch kennen denn alle und
zwar ist das der typ der wirklich alle
fünf minuten seien poetischen status hat
der halt wirklich alle fünf minuten
gewechselt wird ja irgendwie finde ich
das komisch da denke ich mir so her hast
du nichts besseres zu tun
komische status da rein zu klatschen
waren 13 uhr wieder zeit für neuen
status was können wir dann schreiben an
google fließen guter so motto eiskalt
durch das leben marschieren aber nie
vergessen dass man das herz eines engels
besitzt irgendwie gefällt mir das status
von eben nicht mehr
es gibt es denn sonst noch ich kann hier
einfach irgendwas aus dem refrain von
einem lied nehmen wie wäre es mit bush
said you were mine
das passt doch das ist gut dass nebenbei
ja heute so viel dazu erstmalig will
sagen wenn ihr bock habt dass ich öfter
so zeh nach videos machen wir auf jeden
fall mal richtig für überhaupt anlass
der rumba oder schreibt sie kommentare
wird mich sehr freuen
als sonst würde ich sagen instagram war
alles schon eingebildet eben ab und
verwenden um nicht versuche passen wir
sehen uns nicht wir sehen uns halt so
nächsten montag wieder aber hier geht es
weiter mit meinem anderen cenap video
zehn arten von stamp nutzern text auf
check zum auf jeden fall und japan lendl